electricity a form of energy governed by
the flow of charge it's the reason you
can watch this video and hear me speak
we're also electric we're bioelectric
within our bodies our electrical
currents and electrical potentials that
are generated by cells that make up our
bodies
in fact it's the reason we're alive it's
involved in neuronal signaling in our
brains enables our heart muscles to
contract and to transport glucose to
name a few disturbance of this
electrical signaling has been implicated
in many pathophysiological conditions
including cancer diabetes and heart
failure
however this bioelectrical signaling is
also important for development and
rejuvenation and so this suggests if we
can better understand these
bioelectrical networks
it suggests a roadmap for exploiting
bioelectrical signaling for
interventions addressing developmental
disorders regenerative medicine cancer
reprogramming and synthetic
bioengineering
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where if that intro got you
excited you're listening to the right
video as we're going to talk about the
long-awaited topic of the bioelectrical
network or in other words the
information that is present in our
bodies and that of all living organisms
that comes from the transport of ions
across a membrane so we'll discuss what
it is in more detail why it's
interesting and how it could be
exploited therapeutically for a variety
of areas i mentioned in the intro
so before we jump into the biology just
a tiny bit of physics electricity
by definition electricity is a form of
energy resulting from the existence of
charged particles or even simpler
electricity is the flow of charge and
guess what as i just mentioned we have
charged particles in our bodies and
these charges can be moved across the
membrane of cells by different proteins
estimates are that 20 to 50 percent of
our atp supply the energy currency of
the cell is actually used up by one of
these cheeky proteins
this protein is currently in a membrane
and so that's good because it's a
membrane protein and it's carrying ions
across the membrane but it's better to
refer to it as its actual name the
sodium potassium pump
it pumps ions here sodium and potassium
ions across the cell membrane
so it takes sodium ions which have a
positive charge one direction and
potassium ions which also have a
positive charge
in the other direction
and so we have movement of charges and
this movement requires energy in the
form of atp
but that's just one protein out of many
that do similar things
that is they move charged molecules
across membranes so as you can see our
cells are electric
now this isn't just important for us
functioning right now but it was and
while so is important for our
development how we went from one cell to
fully grown humans now you might be
thinking but you're wrong the dna has
that information
well well yes dna has a lot of
information but we've sequenced the
genome and there's no direct instruction
for how to control the size the shape
the symmetry and the structure of the
body as it grows
so where does that information actually
come from well this is a fascinating
question that has been of interest to
many scientists particularly
developmental biologists for a very long
time
and also of the biologist michael levin
whose review article inspired me making
this video aza's research covers the
intersection of bioelectricity with
development and rejuvenation he also
tweets a lot about books he's reading
and i think he's now partly to blame for
my humongous reading list
anyway what i mean to say is that
genomics is not the only instructions
available to a cell and that's not
really surprising you see biology can be
noisy
yet the final outcome us humans is
pretty similar
we all have two eyes a mouth eyebrows
all in roughly the same region
and even crazier cells can still work
together to produce the final
functioning organisms even if you put up
the starting conditions as you can see
here in this experiment performed in
frogs
you can take a tadpole so the i guess
the premature version of a frog and make
its face abnormal
and then rearrangement will occur such
that a normal frog face is still built
and there's also experiments done in
salamanders whereby if you take the tail
and graft it to the side of the
salamander it will remodel into a limb
and in some animals if you amputate them
they can still produce a perfect
replacement which is madness it's like
absolutely madness when you think about
it
except it's not because something is
clearly going on something that we
should be able to understand
the cells are clearly adapting to some
radical unpredictable changes in their
morphogenesis
so in the case of the tadpole frog
example with the face rearranging
there's clearly no genetically hard
wired information for these
rearrangements
instead the genome seems to be encoding
some kind of cellular system that has
plasticity
and this plasticity helps the organism
cope with achieving the final morphology
of the frog despite these radical
unpredictable changes
so there is evidently some information
above the genetic information but how do
the cells know when everything is in the
right place how did they know they were
in the wrong place or if they were
forming the wrong structure well firstly
this brings us on to the idea of
anatomical homeostasis
basically the idea that organisms can
activate cell behaviors that somehow
reduce the errors between the current
state and the target morphological
states say the correctly formed organism
but the really important and interesting
question is well how is this information
specified and read by the cells
for example orton forms the developing
organ that it's reached the correct
shape and size without further growing
to form a tumor
well what are the possibilities i think
there's at least three
one being biochemical signals say what
proteins or small molecules are present
and how much of them secondly
biomechanical forces
physics like stretching and squashing or
pressure and then lastly as i've kind of
alluded to already in this video
bioelectrical communication
and so we're going to focus on that
latter strategy for the remainder of
this video
so as a brief recap we've already
established that our cells are electric
and they're different from the cables
that power our electrical devices
because here the electrical signals are
coming from the movement of ions across
the cell membrane commonly sodium
potassium and calcium
and this is an essential feature of all
living cells
and the cool thing is that it now seems
that these electrical communications
between and within cells can control
things like gene expression and cell
behavior
so let's take a look at some examples to
explain what i mean and then we'll
discuss the potential for therapeutic
intervention
so a very very important concept to
understand for this video is the fact
that cells have a so-called electrical
potential across their membrane and this
is because there's these different
proteins that i've already shown you
that can actively or passively move
these ions across the membrane
and so because these ions have charges
you can end up with one side of the
membrane being more positive than the
other
and so the kind of fancy way of
describing this is to say that if it's
more positive it's hyper polarized and
if it's more negative it's depolarized
and so it turns out our cells in kind of
normal conditions have a more negative
charge on the inside of the cell and so
typically we refer to this as its
resting potential
and so altering then this electrical
potential making it more or less
positive turns out to be a key parameter
in the regulation of cellular behaviors
such as cellular replication cell death
and cell migration
now the beautiful thing is that you can
have fancy dyes to detect the electrical
potential and see them in model
organisms
so take this image here of a planarian
flatworm
what you can see here is that there are
spatially organized bioelectrical
patterns
there are red bits and blue bits where
red meaning depolarized so has a more
positive electrical potential and blue
means regions where it's more negative
so it's hyperpolarized
and these differences are thought to
help determine polarity in the organism
so which region ends up becoming the
head of the planarian and which region
ends up becoming the cell so what then
determines the bioelectric states
well quite simply as i've mentioned
these the membrane potential depends on
which and how much of these ions are
present within the cell and that depends
on what proteins are expressed in the
membrane of these cells that control the
transport of these ions
so the expression of the eye internal
proteins
i say well then what governs the
expression of the ion channel proteins
and their subsequent activation
well many things but frankly that isn't
what we're going to focus on here what's
important to understand is that in
response to changing environments the
activity of these channels can change
and with it the resting potential
this change in potential can generate a
signal within the cell to lead to the
appropriate response for example a
change in gene expression
another interesting idea to understand
is that two cells can have the same
electrical potential but the potential
may be generated by different ions and
different channel proteins in the
membrane and the evidence currently
suggests that a specific electrical
potential
can trigger for example eye development
anywhere in the body regardless of which
ion channel protein or even which iron
was used to implement that state of
membrane potential
so let's return to that planarian i
showed you earlier with the red the
polarized region forming ahead and the
blue hyperpolarized section forming the
tail
well the interesting thing is that
experimentally you can transiently
perturb this pattern
by using different blockers that inhibit
proteins such as drugs that inhibit
these ion channel proteins
and so what that effectively does is it
resets the membrane potential and so it
results in both sides of the planarian
being depolarized
so what would you expect
well two heads of course which is what
you can see here
and
most interestingly is that these two
headed worms when they're cut and they
can regenerate they go on to keep making
two headed worms and so it also suggests
that the bioelectric network exhibits
memory and this also provides direct
evidence that perturbing the bioelectric
network can have really strong
phenotypic effects
but whilst this is all interesting what
about humans and is there anything more
relevant than having two heads
well this leads me on to the concept of
morphoceuticals
therapeutics that could be used to aid
in rejuvenation treating developmental
disorders or maybe even cancer by
altering these bioelectrical networks
present in cells
and as stated in this review there are
four attractive reasons why interfering
in bioelectric states could be valuable
for the design of therapeutics
firstly as we've seen
small changes in this network can have a
large effect on morphogenesis
so in other words you can trigger
large-scale changes in growth and form
without having to micromanage individual
details
secondly it may act as an early decision
making switch that selects downstream
morphogenetic programs
in other words the idea that a single
treatment could have prolonged
influences over the growth of the
organism
thirdly there are many drugs already
available that target these different
eye internal proteins their so-called
drugable
obviously you would first have to work
out which channels you'd want to open
and close and whereabouts in the body
before you do it
and then lastly is the idea that the
impact may not necessarily be local
as voltage patterns can also propagate
so you could have maybe long range
control
and this may help to target hard to
reach sites
however this also may be a complication
if you wanted to target a specific place
without having these long range impacts
and so all in all this more physical
idea is more of a top-down approach
which if effective could coordinate a
myriad of downstream responses
such that treatment may only be needed
once as effectively you make a tweak in
a higher level system and then you just
let the body deal with the complexities
now this research still is inevitably in
the early stages but it is very exciting
to see how
it may circumvent some of the challenges
that are associated with other
regenerative techniques such as how
exactly you get cells to
form specific organs for replacement you
could just let the body deal with it
but there are also some great
possibilities as michael even describes
on sean carroll's podcast here
i think we just don't know the code
enough if we if we understood how to
reprogram uh correctly these uh these
target uh patterns i think we would be
looking at something like an anatomical
compiler you know this is like our our
vision when i talk about what's the end
game for our group you know when can you
give up and go home because everything's
done i think what we're looking at is
something like an anatomical compiler
that you sit down much like computer
aided drawing you
basically just draw a picture of a
schematic of the animal or plant that
you want and if we knew what we were
doing the system would uh decompose that
into a set of stimuli that you would
give cells to get them to build that
particular thing not because you're
going to micromanage the you know the
the you're not going to 3d print
individual stem cell derivatives but
you're going to
rewrite the goal state that the cells
are accessing the cell collective i
should be more precise the cell
collective is accessing to know what to
build and when to stop
why do you think this work is very
fascinating so much so i'm going to end
with this quote that i found on
wikipedia because i like it
life is ultimately an electrochemical
enterprise as i said i think there are
many fascinating discoveries to come
so with that thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening